when people think of the Netherlands
many think of tulips blooming in all
colors of the rainbow like the do at
Koken HOF outside Amsterdam
right now there are more than 1000
different varieties on display
so there's a lot to check out on an
Easter stroll through the world's
biggest flower garden the flowers and
the colors let's make my Easter feeling
the happiness of Easter and like the
whole meeting of spring so and it makes
you think that God has blessed us and
stuff with all his creations the tulip
has a long history one almost as
colorful as the flower itself the first
tulip bulbs arrived in the Netherlands
four hundred years ago they originally
came from Central Asia the rare flowers
quickly became popular among rich
merchants tulip mania followed as the
price of bulbs soared everybody wanted
to show that they had more money than
the neighbor and they started to collect
the beautiful tulip flowers and tulip
bulbs that were really something special
in those days and prices rose to an
incredible level and the highest point
in Amsterdam for three tulip bulbs a big
house was sold for just three children
bulbs this floral display featuring
Dutch canal houses is a reminder of that
era spectators paid top dollar for the
flaming tulip back then a virus created
the flowers streaks today crossbreeding
generates the effect
during the boom the black tulip was in
big demand it's not really black but
dark violet
people come here in the park year after
year asking mr. simmering where's the
black tulip can you show it to us and we
do have it but the real black one to be
honest it doesn't exist that it will
never come this painting illustrates the
mood in Amsterdam during tulip mania in
1630 but the tulip craze lasted just a
few years the bubble burst in 1637
although people still make jokes about
tulip mania centuries later and when the
economic bubble was over people started
to realize how they behaved that it was
really a crazy time and a crazy thing to
do to pay about ninety thousand dollars
for just one tulip bulb
these days almost everyone in Europe can
afford a bunch of tulips and the
Netherlands is the world's biggest tulip
producer more than eight hundred
thousand visitors come to the coke and
hoof Gardens every year
Johann Brom and 30 others spend 10
months preparing the annual spring tulip
show every year they plant brand-new
varieties all in all it takes 25 years
to breathe enough bulbs to make them
commercially available
with the modern Philips is much more
bigger most of the time a of all
different colors and different size of
flower and when the the modern men are
to plan them it's like this to all mix
them that's what I like
about 7 million tulip bulbs are planted
in the fall so that they will bloom by
spring time for the show it's the
perfect antidote to Europe's long winter
it's beautiful it's marvelous I mean
there's nothing like this anywhere else
I've never been anywhere like this is
beautiful for centuries after tulip
mania the flowers still alors it's a
great symbol for Europe's Spring
Awakening